[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une gêne qui indique que je n'ai pas
forcément des tâches plus rageant c'est
donc voilà je suis venu vous parler
comme ça vient d'être dit deux parties
armand de la mémoire et de la mémoire
des conflits
donc je suis président d'une association
départementale qui s'appelle l'anacr
association nationale des anciens
combattants et résistants et amis de la
résistance qui vous a été indiqué et je
vais vous parler de ce que peut être la
transmission de la mémoire au travers
notamment des moments commémoratif et au
travers du travail que font ces
associations dans le domaine patriotique
et de la mémoire des conflits
bien évidemment ça vient d'être dit le
conflit visait particulièrement selon la
demande de votre association le premier
conflit mondial
la nacre est une association qui a été
créée en 1945 c'est à dire au lendemain
du second flux mondiale qui rassemblait
essentiellement des résistants issus des
francs tireurs et partisans qui est une
moment de résistance créé par le parti
communiste de l'époque mais en 1952
quelques années plus tard l'anac va
s'ouvrir à tous les résistants tous les
anciens combattants de la résistance
et puis elle va faire cette chose que je
vous recommande particulière elle va en
2006 accueillir les amis de la
résistance qui est vous l'avez compris
un moyen de pérenniser la vie de
l'association puisque par la loi de la
vie les anciens résistants disparaissent
les uns après les autres
vous avez sur la table en bas sans doute
remarqué le portrait d'une très jolie
dame
il s'appelle lucienne fabre il vient de
nous quitter
qui est décédé il ya quelques semaines
et qui était une grande résistance de
notre département et qui à l'âge de 20
ans engagé sa vie dans la résistance
on risque évidemment de la perdre et
c'est un symbole de la résistance et en
plus de la résistance départementale je
vais donc vous parler de la mémoire
parce que comme ça de l'art c'est moi
qui fais le pari voilà donc comme c'est
indiqué là je pensais que c'était un
lieu ouvert d'entré donc
je vous laisse réfléchir à cette
citation d'aimé césaire mégi rajouterai
peut-être le but en ce qui concerne les
conflits notamment la seconde guerre
mondiale un peuple sans mémoire est un
peuple sans avenir ça veut dire que
entretenir la mémoire c'est peut-être
répondre aux aspirations des anciens
combattants de la première guerre que de
la deuxième guerre mondiale qui disaient
les uns les autres
plus jamais ça voilà et donc la mémoire
d'un peuple c'est une mémoire qui doit
permettre d'empêcher la reconduction des
conflits des guerres je passe parce que
c'est pas le sujet sur le fait que l'on
pourra discuter de l'absence des
conflits cédé hier mais bon mais ce que
je veux vous dire c'est que cette
mémoire dont je vais vous parler elle se
transmet et cela n'est pas j'avais cette
citation de berck sonne ça n'est pas une
mémoire qui fonctionne de la même façon
que les ordinateurs que vous utilisez
les uns les autres pour vous études et
autres noms ont réussi un petit peu donc
la mémoire des ordinateurs elles
s'empilent et puis on peut travailler la
mémoire à partir de cet empilement la
mémoire des hommes
elle fonctionne avec une caractéristique
caractéristiques particulières qui est
celle de l'oubli c'est ce que nous a dit
personnes les peuples l'oubli voilà on
oublie parce qu'on a une mémoire
sélective et dont la tendance générale
et ne tourner plutôt vers l'avenir c'est
à dire de tourner plutôt vers la pensée
du monde actuel et d'oublier le passé
mais il est très important de conserver
se passer parce que s'il y a eu la
résistance comme vous voyez là il ya eu
aussi ça la déportation à auschwitz
alors je crois que celui là vous le
connaissez puisque c'est le wagon du
mémorial de compiègne l'autre fait un
wagon vous voyez pourquoi
et puis il ya eu ça bien sûr et donc
mark twain est aussi karl marx nous dise
l'histoire ne se reproduit pas elle rime
mardi elle bégaie prime j'ai choisi ça
n'est pas très important mais il faut
surtout savoir que l'histoire si elle ne
se reproduit pas elle peut reproduire
des phénomènes identiques ou similaires
donc le travail
des associations comme la mienne c'est
d'abord d'assurer une solidarité avec
les résistants ils leur restent vivent
encore je viens ont quitté un avant de
venir vous rencontrer et d'ailleurs sur
la table vous avez des documents qui
nous a lui même fourni à un brassard
ffic était le sien il ya des documents
historiques qui montre qu'il a été un
grand résistant il à 95 ans et il est en
santé précaire donc les résistants il
faut assurer la solidarité avec eux les
aider dans leur vie
c'est une question que pose la nac mais
c'est une question que posent les
pouvoirs publics aux six titres et
décorations de résistants qui leur
permettent d'avoir aussi des moyens de
subsistance donc ça c'est une partie
importante
il ya les commémorations donc je dis un
mot qui sont aussi un moyen d'entretenir
la mémoire je dis un mot sur laquelle
les commémorations de la première guerre
mondiale
tout simplement parce que nous sommes
vous êtes nous sommes tous concernés et
nous particulièrement alors les
étudiants je pense que vous n'êtes pas
tout tous résident dans l'oise mais vous
étudiez à compiègne et les cérémonies du
centenaire de la première guerre
mondiale vont se terminer en novembre
2018 dans l'oise à compiègne à la
clairière de rethondes où le président
de la république va inviter en grand
nombre des chefs d'état qui ont été
concernés par le premier conflit et où
déjà il ya un conflit de mémoire puisque
je vous parlais aussi les conflits de
mémoire puisque les anciens résistants
les anciens un pardon les associations
d'anciens combattants et d'anciens
résistants se sont manifestés mais
partir mancelle d'anciens combattants
parce que les résistantes sont pas
concernés par la première guerre mais
les anciens combattants ont expliqué que
c'était bien d'inviter les chefs d'état
mais qu'il fallait aussi c'était normal
à la dernière au dernier moment du de la
commémoration du centenaire de leur
donner une place dans ces commémorations
donc il ya un débat avec les autorités
pour savoir quelle place on va donner
aux autorités représentant les états et
quelle place on va donner aux
associations ce qui montre aussi que la
mémoire n'est pas un sujet qui n'est pas
vivant qu'il n'ait pas travaillé je vais
en donner un certain nombre d'exemples
en tout cas la première guerre mondiale
aura eu quatre années de commémoration
et c'est un conflit majeur mais je peux
parler de la seconde guerre
puisque vous êtes étudiant et vous savez
pertinemment qu'il y a un lien très
tenue entre la première et la seconde
guerre mondiale puisque alors je vais
m'engager je suis pas historien je peux
me le permettre
il ya une commande un lien qui fait que
les le peuple allemand a considéré qu'il
avait été maltraité par la première
guerre mondiale pas seulement par le
conflit lui-même mais par le traité de
versailles et que tout ça a généré
l'arrivée de forces l'extrême par les
élections gens dire à un mot tout à
l'heure au pouvoir en allemagne
la création du nazisme est là qu on se
laisse vite que vous connaissez donc
commémoration mai commémoration aussi
pour la deuxième guerre mondiale puisque
demain 27 mai ce sera la journée
nationale de la résistance alors on en
parle peu mais elles existent et elles
existent parce que l on parle le moins
parce qu'elle a été créé en 2013 c'est à
dire très récemment
on crée tous les ans maintenant on a une
journée nationale de la résistance et
les certes un certain nombre de
municipalités comme mort par le dépôt de
gerbe par différentes initiatives et
puis puisque nous sommes dans les
colorations les anniversaires
vous savez tous bien sûr que nous sommes
dans le 75e anniversaire de la création
du conseil national de la résistance de
ses nerfs qui avait pour président alors
là faut que j'aille vite
jean moulin qui a créé le cnr a sur les
recommandations la demande du général de
gaulle et le clr le conseil national de
la résistance c'est le rassemblement de
tous les mouvements de la résistance en
france qu'ils soient communistes
chrétien de droite de gauche tout ce qui
a formé la résistance du peuple français
au travers de différents mouvements qui
vont se réunir alors j'ai pas trop le
temps ne reste qu'une minute mais
évidemment ne voyait pas les choses
comme dans les séries télévisées se
réunir en 1942 réunir à paris tous les
mouvements de la résistance tous leurs
responsables vous comprendrez bien que
c'est prendre un risque colossale aux
voeux de l'occupant au vu de la
répression au vu des risques mais ils
vont réussir à se réunir et ils vont
entre eux arias les partis politiques il
ya des associations il ya des
organisations il ya des syndicats
notamment la cgt mais aussi la cftc qui
à l'époque étaient les deux syndicats
les plus importants et qui vont
constituer un programme pour les
lendemain de la deuxième guerre mondiale
qu on a appelé d'un monde merveilleux
qui s'appelait et jours heureux et qui
sera mise en oeuvre par les
gouvernements du général de gaulle au
lendemain de la première de la deuxième
guerre mondiale contenu démocratique et
sociale avancé je vous laisse il y en a
un exemplaire sur la table en bas du
programme du cnr
donc voilà les commémorations sont
importants mais la mémoire n'est pas
quelque chose de figé c'est quelque
chose qui se travaille et je voudrais
prendre un exemple un seul
vous avez tous évidemment en tête cette
tragédie de l'extermination du peuple
juif de la 6 millions d'hommes et de
femmes et d'enfants et de personnes
âgées de juifs qui ont été examinés
exterminés dans les camps de
concentration dans d'extermination
pardon nazi notamment aux tweets fait
évidemment une tragédie mais c'est une
tragédie qui a tendance géante à dire
qu'elles rentrent en conflit pour
utiliser le terme de la journée avec
d'autres éléments de l'art et de la
mémoire
mais elle travaille aussi la mémoire en
ce sens qu'elle s'impose par sa
dimension tragique par son ampleur par
le fait que jamais il avait été fait
jamais donc ça c'est pas bien de dire ça
mais rarement il a il ya eu des
génocides d'une telle ampleur dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
mais en même temps je voulais vous dire
parti hier mon jeune femme qui sont là
qu'il est parti de combien ils le 23
janvier 1943 un train de déportés qui
comprenait 2 149 femmes 243 femme fera
non je ne m'abuse le 23 janvier 1943 il
est parti en direction de schwyz il est
revenu au chaud its 49 femmes
sur les 230 49 femmes les votes ont été
assassinés et c'était la totalité des
déportés de caractère politique elle
étaient déportés parce qu'elle avait été
résistante parce qu'elle était engagé
dans les forces politiques et elles ont
été déportés et assassinés
voyez que la mémoire peut aussi revêtir
je pense que la plupart de vous saviez
et peut revêtir différentes formes et là
on a un exemple concret ensuite je
prends un autre exemple on a eu le fin
c'est le même exemple en juillet 1942 un
départ de convois d'un convoi d'hommes
1140 hommes déportés politiques
il en est rentré 140 voilà ce sont aussi
des chiffres tragiques qui n'ont
évidemment pas l'ampleur de la shoah
mais qui représente aussi un problème de
mémoire il faut faire connaître parce
que c'est aussi tous à la dimension du
conflit de la résistance à la guerre
donc
j'ai pris ces deux exemples là mais je
voudrais également à sir attirer votre
attention sur l'importance de la
résistance dans la libération du pays
puisque le général eisenhower chef des
forces alliées qui ont libéré la france
considérait que l'apport de la
résistance à cette libération à
l'arrivée des forces alliées pour
libérer la france et de l'autre côté des
forces de l'armée rouge qui sont
intervenus aussi pour libérer leur pays
ou de la libérer l'europe
eh bien il considérait que c'était
l'équivalent la résistance et l'un
concours qu'elle a apporté à la
libération de 15 division armée et il
l'a déclaré écrit et donc voilà ça me
permet de vous dire que ne perdez jamais
de vue si vous voulez bien que la
résistance est une affaire populaire
c'est à dire ce sont une partie du
peuple français l'autre partie a choisi
la passivité et l'autre partie a choisi
de collaborer mais une partie du peuple
a choisi de résister de ne pas se
laisser faire au prix de sacrifices
terrible au prix de la vie on peut voir
ici par exemple marcel letort et lucien
tels qu'ils sont deux résistant décédé
confié noah qui en 1942 le 1er mai ont
défié l'occupant par des actes de
résistance notamment à l'apport de la
luftwaffe qui avait installé un à
compiègne ce sont des hommes le simple
des sommes modestes qui ont été l'un et
l'autre déporté à dachau
certains ont été fusillés d'ailleurs
parmi ces ce mouvement de résistance qui
pour vous dire qu'il était populaire
étaient issus du club de football de
margny les compiègne voilà et ils ont
choisi de sacrifier de se sacrifier pour
la liberté de notre pays autre grand
résistant raymond aubrac et j'ai choisi
le titre de son livre parce qu'il porte
pour titre passage de témoin on est bien
dans une idée du conflit de la mémoire
et de la transmission de cette mémoire
passage de témoin il a écrit un livre
pour complice il est mort aussi aux
complices
vous avez quelques images de la
résistance est donc cette remarque de
françois mauriac qui font lire
intégralement vous êtes étudiant vous
savez seule la classe ouvrière est resté
dans sa masse dans sa masse ça ne veut
pas dire çà doit veut pas dire les
ouvriers ça veut dire la classe ouvrière
et dans sa masse ça veut dire pour une
part importante pour la classe sociale
elle-même mais fidèle à la patrie
profané ce qui confirme le caractère
populaire de la résistance voilà je vais
terminer en vous disant alors je sais
plus si je le lui ai écrit je crois
qu'elle est vraie la troisième citation
c'est celle de bertold brecht qui a dit
il est encore fécond le ventre ou surgi
la bête immonde
il est encore fécond le vent d'où surgit
la bâtiment est malheureusement est
malheureusement et c'est aussi un rôle
de mon association
malheureusement on peut constater la
résurgence aujourd'hui non pas de formes
identiques histoire ne se reproduit pas
elle bégaie
mais de mouvements nationalistes de
mouvements d'extrême droite de
mouvements xénophobes qui trop petit à
petit prennent de la place et des
pouvoirs c'est donc aussi un rôle de
l'association d'attirer l'attention des
jeunes générations et vous en faites
partie excusez-moi consistant à leur
dire attention attention histoire ne se
reproduit pas elle bégaie
il peut y avoir des formes semblables
je vous rappelle je les dis que hitler
est venu au pouvoir non pas par des
voies violente mais par la voie
démocratique
il a été élu il n'était pas fou il a
organisé
la domination du nazisme il voulait
rayer sur l'europe et pour ça il l'a
fait je cite comme ça
messieurs messieurs de l'infrastructure
va falloir donc au moment où j'allais
dire le deuxième conflit mondial c'est
50 millions de morts dont beaucoup de
victimes civiles
c'est considérable il est terrible par
exemple je pense à ça en vous parlant
qu'une ville comme noyon a été détruite
au cours de la première guerre mondiale
par les armées alliées qui ont en ayant
donné l' ultimatum aux armées allemandes
de quitter noyau comme ils n'ont pas
quitté les eaux des three lions
il est terrible que vous le savez des
villes françaises ont été détruites par
les armées alliées pour chasser le nez
les nazis également les troupes
allemandes
le lin beernaert de deux des dix villes
françaises donc rien n'est jamais acquis
à l'homme ni sa force ni ses faiblesses
disait l'autre je vous laisse réfléchir
celui qui disait ça et puis le travail
de mémoire est un travail essentiel qui
consiste encore une fois a rappelé ce
comté les conflits leurs causes leurs
origines les associations dont je vais
parler dont la mienne ne sont évidemment
pas les seuls il ya toute une série de
gens qui nous parlent de la mémoire
il ya évidemment les historiens c'est
les premiers mais il ya également les
philosophes
il ya également les hommes politiques
qui nous en parle aussi il ya également
les chanteurs il ya également les poètes
il ya également toute une série de gens
je vous renvoie jean ferrat et la nuit
et brouillard chanson qui restait
marquée dans le dans le marbre de la
culture populaire et et de chanson
française est en tout cas moi je termine
en disant vous disant que je compte sur
vous dans la place que vous choisissez
dans la société française pour ne jamais
oublier et pour penser que chaque
citoyen un rôle à jouer dans la
transmission de la mémoire
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]